hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute mein name ist
krankhaft der sebastians name ist
sebastian wir vielleicht eine ecke sehen
ist das hier ein werbevideo und zwar das
letzte video aus der google play
kampagne dafür hab ich würde etwas
besonderes ausgedacht und zwar seht ihr
hier neben mir ein basketballkorb man
einfach aufklappen kann wow und zu
setzen nicht dazu habe ich natürlich
meinen google pixel bei mir kam auf dem
pixel eine app real passt mir fällt
gerade auf sollte das video was bei real
wird flüssig schade denn also alles
bestens wir müssen wieder ich schlitze
leihen wenn ihr euch jetzt in die irre
geführt fühlte aber gestiegen heute
passiert bei real börse digital
wir beginnen mit dem spielmodus spiel
halten sk logischerweise macht das gegen
sebastian spielhalle
ich guck mal hier auf starten ihr sich
über mit ecke bälle übrig fünf stück da
steht zwar beide übrig aber für jeden
verworfenen bei werde ich geboxt und
getreten oder getreten so beginnen ja
einfach mal ist es relativ schwer so man
muss genau die kraft dosieren und die
richtung auch noch so ersten treffer
habe ich sah und zweiter treffer sehr
gut dritter treffer die rede kein
fünfter ich schwöre sie zwar gerade
leicht aus weil ihr kennt das nicht wenn
man ein produkt werden sie seien
vielleicht auch aber es ist richtig
schwierig eigentlich so fünfter und das
könnte also meinen erleben nichts
getroffen
egal jetzt auf einmal geht es nur bisher
können die 54 treffer sechster und
siebter ein
ja seit dem 18
ada leben gott das war schrecklich ich
habe noch zwei bieter übrig habe jetzt
zehn treffern
ok 11 12 13 14
das war 14 treffer ist es richtig gut
verzichten grenze versuchte direkt mal
glück okay let's check und da ist es
drinnen steht sie manchmal auf mich
bauen zwar direkt neben ihr ein hast du
ja wo laufen wir 10 1 2 als im 2 wie
viele der modelle übrig zwar jetzt gab
zweiter vereinsmeister im maul also wie
kannst du im reallife aufbessern
okay der flotte ist immerhin mal da muss
ich kurz meine ehre retten
ja der ist auch 34 und alt ob denn nicht
drin ist dem ob sie waren komm schon
erst wenn flotte ist ja immer so der war
auch gut gezielt jungen 1
komm schon sechs stücken oder damit habe
ich die erste digitale change gewonnen
mit jeder reist ist mobile gaming das
wichtigste in meinem leben ja sebastian
will ich sagen denk mal kurz das pixel
zur seite auch wenn es schwer fällt nein
erstmal sehr und wir springen jetzt
sozusagen ins echte leben schwimmer
nicht nehmen dann bekommen leute wir
haben hier lieber auf dem boden
nummerierung angebracht und wir machen
jetzt im prinzip genau das gleiche also
die rekordversuche und wenn man einfach
nichts trifft kriegt was vorteile
abgezogen okay ich gebe hierzu nummer
eins muss immer zwischen beiden füßen
sein
alles klar vielleicht sollte ich beim
digitalen la digitalen belasse ich es
dann nochmals drei so gut wird dir du
bist mein glück den dritten habe ich
noch schwieriger gestalten und weist der
um die ecke hier so müssen die füße
stehen also die nummer zwischen füßen ok
und das darf man sich über den
[Musik]
wir haben rein gekommen dass diana die
regel macht war das bisher alles legitim
dass ich nicht überleben
so gehen wir als nummer vier ich habe
tatsächlich mit drei würfen drei
fehlversuche an dieser stelle ich mich
bei meiner mutter bedanken komme ich
muss mich mal kurz konzentrieren und das
[Musik]
heißt ich kann jetzt weiter werden und
erst dann die name aus der wand geholt
sehr gut finde ich gut dass man hier
nächster treff fachleute jetzt gesehen
mit 102 31
es ist so lächerlich ist ohne spaß ist
eine abend mit letztjährige schwere
trainer aber ich würde nicht sagen dass
ich mich selbst geworfen
dass der letzte versuch falls du nicht
triffst so leute jetzt ist es sebastian
seitz erstelle ich möchte zu punkt nur 1
und machte seinen ersten wurf brauch
erst mal waren es noch merken also man
muss das schiff zwischen beiden haben
muss man natürlich okay fand aber hey
leute ich habe das ja schon wesentlich
rückseite ist naja jetzt kommt zu punkt
2 lässt natürlich besonders schwierig
falls ja was ist hier los ist
dann geht es noch okay okay okay okay
damit leute würde ich sagen dann brechen
sich also bald soweit wäre das video
jetzt gekettet sebastian hat daran
dennoch 1000 körper geworfen es ist also
1000 zu zwei ausgefertigt machen wir mal
weiter als nächstes schwimmzeiten modus
also wie viele körbe schafft man in
einer minute im echten leben und
digitale zurzeit modus eine minute zeit
los geht das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm
wenn man daneben wird kosten selber zu
halten ok nein die zwei dierig voreilig
ziel lauten wird welchen trefft 1 und 2
jetzt sehr gut auch das kannst du stark
sein 13
okay ich war der kopf hinter anzuwenden
wenn die daten dann hat er ist ja genau
das ist eben auch so nationen ist was
ist denn hier los ok sehr gut 4 machen
hälfte der zeit hatten wir vier
körperkontrolle kannst du dich okay ich
muss mich vielleicht ein bisschen
anderer wert 5 markiert so komplex ist
eigentlich sieben schmutz ab 9
für ihn zählt aber komm jetzt schnell
die kosten allein 1 sekunde top ich
hätte noch einen machen können
wahrscheinlich
das waren tatsächlich zehn stück bisher
war ich der könig ist das spielst du
warst das spiel also gaming auch schon
direkt davor ok und der verbände und der
zweite auf flores der dritte nach komm
schon du hast drei körper aktuelle ja
und wir sind damals zwölf vorbeigegangen
langfristig glaube ich und 56 sekunden
und kurt 7 oder ist langsam
nein nein und ja oder die versprechen
gerade dabei 75 sehr gut sehr gut muss
jetzt acht ok am besten was gar keine
und er ist ja ok einer durfte konkret
und hier wohl
erzähle ich hatte damals sehen die serie
erzählt der in 11 7 sekunden noch und
nein jetzt übrig aber ich habe mich
heute nicht so als ob ich jetzt keiner
macher durch einen der gewinne kommt
schon leute alle daneben ja um das ganze
relativ einfach zu gestalten bleibt
japan einer position stehen und zwar vor
dem korb bei der nummer eins okay der
tiger beginn und ein guter einkauf
dürfte weltweit zu den magen
foto k 2144 seit 11 12 sekunden und 213
das verletzten war glaube ich mich nicht
lässt 16
ja ok aber in bous wurden geshootet von
kran den bauch du hast dein fußball
einstehen
ok grund
die chips war erster treffer 1 okay das
gehört mich dass wir mit guido okay der
mann heißt pier 53
das würde nächstes dass wir zunächst das
ganz okay sehr gut jetzt sind die zeit
55 derzeit 1,5 weiterhin bei 5 619
schnitt die sagen dass stimmen 778 grüße
genau seinen nachbarn machen weiterhin
achter und das war's ich habe dir
endlich die abreibung verpasst ich
dachte das ist viel besser als ich wenn
du machst du gerne musik wenn ihr
aufmerksam mitgezählt hat habt ihr
festgestellt ist jetzt 22 steht
sebastian mal wieder gewonnen ich einmal
und jeder einmal ein spiel gewonnen
heisst 2 2
wir klären das ganze jetzt wie echte
männer und zwar indem wir ein ball
spielen und wer mehr treffer schafft am
stück hat geworden dann kam alles ganz
schnell verweisen aber sofort wenn du
den ersten treffer nicht magst du
verfolgst du kannst natürlich glück
haben und die anderen schaffen ersten
auch nicht dann geht es natürlich die in
dearborn
ich bin echt ich bin echt aufgeregt das
ist ein normales video ich bin echt
aufgeregt erster ehe und der könnte gut
sein der punkt gut
der wagen auf dem green verkauf bitte
bitte das hängt jetzt nicht viel ab von
diesem ein fingerwischen aber ich sage
so gekonnt estate gewinnen oder mir die
nächste chance geben und
so ist gut gemacht wurde und bis heute
frage ist aber was leute damit endet
auch das video und leider leider habe
ich verloren ist stört mich eigentlich
ganz und gar nicht was ich verloren habe
auf jeden fall ein großes dankeschön
noch mal ein google an der stelle ich
habe die kampagne wirklich cool mobile
gaming hatte ich ja davor nicht so
wirklich auch in einem kanal gebracht
aber ich bin sicher das ist jetzt auch
in zukunft weiterhin machen werde
deshalb würde ich sagen leute wenn es
euch gefallen hat und hier die
videoreihe gefallen hat dann lasst auf
jeden fall gerne mal ein leichter ihr
könnt jetzt ein letztes mal abstimmen ob
wir mehr mobile gaming holt und dann
will ich sagen bis zum nächsten mal wir
sehen uns ja